c'est qu'on retourne aux cupr lac russe
notre stagiaire qui s'incruste dans le
maximum d'émissions bien sûr diggle
musical on aime bien mais bien sûr
clémence et le stagiaire de la rédac de
touche pas à mon poste on l'a ici sur
l'image quand il était venu nous voir et
comme beaucoup de stagiaires on n'a rien
trouvé à lui faire faire c'est le
principe d'un stagiaire du coup on a
décidé de l'envoyer s'incruster dans le
plus d'émissions possible pour le tenir
bien éloignée du bureau et il a encore
bien bossé cette semaine regarder
on a vu à l'avant première parisienne du
nouveau spider man mange une pomme à la
cool derrière des stars du film
ah oui on l'a ensuite vu sur ma chaîne
sport dans l'émission de taïg khris en
train de boire un coup à la coupe
montrevault c'est parti soeur mais grâce
à la télé on a appris que clément
commencé à pécho pour la vue pendant
qu'il subsistait sur cette interview
ouais moi c'est plus du milieu rock et à
et en fait on a fait par un style qui
est entre les deux et enfin on l'a vu
sur 1 pfm télé par un duplex devant le
palais de justice déguisés pour passer à
choisir de vivre réellement très cher
puisque le fonds de garantie qui
indemnise les victimes peut ensuite se
retourner contre le conducteur fautif